George of the Jungle was almost Kalel of
Krypton but Brendan Fraser wasn't the
only big name up for consideration in JJ
Abrams lost Superman movie The Brendan
Fraser Renaissance of 2022 was spilled
over into the new year with the whale
star running awards show Acclaim and
accolades for his performance in the
Darren Aronofsky flick including an
Oscar nomination for best actor in late
January Frasier's film career has
reached unprecedented Heights over the
past few months on account of his
powerful portrayal of Charlie a morbidly
obese English teacher who was attempting
to reconnect with his daughter played by
Sadie Singh considered to be his acting
Opus Frazier has come a long way from
his days of swinging through trees and
taking out mummies however there was one
film from the Airhead star's pass that
could have defined as Hollywood career
way earlier but it never got made
spearheaded by JJ Abrams Superman flyby
was supposed to be a renewed take on the
classic DC Comics character with some
new twists revealed in leaked early
drafts of the script like giving a young
Clark Kent glasses but may have led to
help him control his vision abilities or
having his dad's draw Elvis at Earth
years prior to the DC Hero's arrival to
make sure that Kents were suitable
parents as 10 of geek reports it was
said to be the first film in a Trilogy
and would have seen Carl fulfilling a
prophecy as he heir of Krypton according
to Brendan Fraser Warner Brothers wanted
a young actor to play the iconic role
and they brought in numerous Rising
Stars to audition speaking to Howard
Stern on February 7th Frasier recalled
how he and half a dozen others did
screen test for JJ Abrams Superman flyby
movie in 2002. everyone in town was
reading for Superman again we're testing
I think maybe six or seven guys
according to previous reports the list
included Hollywood Young Guns like a
then 20 year old Henry Cavill
Supernatural star Jared Padalecki Ashton
Kutcher Roswell actor Jason bear and as
Frasier revealed during a sit-down with
Stern the late The Fast and Furious star
Paul Walker for Frasier just being able
to have a chance to possibly play such
an iconic and career defining role like
Superman was gratifying but also scary
okay
say you do get the job to be the man of
steel it's going to be chipped on your
gravestone are you okay with that afraid
you then compared taking on the role to
making deal with the devil adding there
was a sorts of Faustian bargain that
went into feeling that and I think
inherently I didn't want to be known for
only one thing because I prided myself
in diversity my whole professional life
I'm not a one-trick pony well Frasier
was fighting with himself over playing
the part the project actually wound up
becoming a Miss Korea boost in his mind
when looking back on everything I felt
disappointed that there was an amazing
opportunity and it didn't come to
fruition so why didn't Superman flyby
take off with Frasier donning the red
cape it had to do a lot with some really
Shenanigans and Studio politics but
Frasier got another big chance at
notoriety in the end as he is one of the
favorites to take home the gold at the
Oscars on March 12th if he can beat out
The Season's Awards Juggernaut Austin
Butler
[Music]